hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
immune profiling of hospitalized covid19
patients
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by beckmann culture
life sciences
to learn more visit beckmancoulter.com
let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr
josephine giles
cancer research institute mark
foundation fellow
university of pennsylvania for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
josephi you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you so much for that
introduction
um so i'm a postdoctoral fellow in john
wary's laboratory at the university of
pennsylvania
and today i'll be telling you about our
work
in trying to investigate the immune
response
to covid19 in hospitalized patients
and i'd like to thank the organizers for
having me
specifically lab roots and beckman
culture life sciences
so sars covi2 is a positive stranded rna
beta corona virus
it is the causative agent for the
disease that we now know
is covid19 as of friday in the united
states there were nine
million cases total this led to a total
of 229 000 deaths
worldwide there have been about 45
million cases leading to 1.18 million
deaths
this disease can have a wide range of
symptoms including some of the ones
listed here
but what we now appreciate is that
individuals infected with stars kobe 2
can lay anywhere on this spectrum from
having absolutely no symptoms at all
to very severe symptoms culminating in
death
and we wanted to understand what is the
immune response to this viral infection
now we know that effective immunity lies
here in the middle
so if you have a robust on target immune
response
that can lead to viral control and
eventual tissue repair
on the right hand side too much of an
immune response
can lead to immunopathology and on the
other side of this
too little of an immune response and by
that we mean
too low in magnitude or too slow maybe
off target
can lead to viral dissemination and then
direct
cytopathic effects of the virus itself
and for covid19 we don't know where we
are in the spectrum
and it's entirely possible that
different patients sort of
have the needle at slightly different
places uh on this scale
and so that may be one reason that we
have some patients with
um you know no symptoms at all and then
some patients that require
hospitalization
so all the work i'll be sharing with you
today has really been the result of a
huge
effort across many different labs and
departments at the university of
pennsylvania
some of which are listed here this work
is really initiated and led on the
clinical side by dr nula meyer
so today i'll be telling you about three
different cohorts
of course the first is our covid19
patients these were all hospitalized at
the university of pennsylvania
many of which were in the icu but some
of which were also in the regular
hospital floor
we also have a group of recovered donors
these are donors that had a confirmed
sars kobe 2 infection
but had not had any symptoms for about
two weeks
and the third is a group of healthy
controls so we received peripheral blood
from these donors
that was processed at various locations
at the university
the samples were then subjected to our
deep immune profiling pipeline
this included high dimensional flow
cytometry
serology and plasma cytokine analysis
in addition there were many different
parts of the clinical data that we
included in our analysis
so when we started to think about how to
analyze this patient cohort
as i mentioned we knew we had about 50
parameters of clinical features
and this included demographic
information as well as medical history
and underlying
pre-existing health conditions various
laboratory tests
as well as the treatments that the
patients were receiving and various
measures of disease severity
so the first thing we wanted to
understand was how all of these clinical
features
related to one another and in doing this
sort of analysis it would give us a
global overview
of this covid19 cohort
so our analytic approach here was to use
spearmint correlation
with the appropriate non-parametric
statistical test
and the exact test that we used depended
on the type of features that were being
compared
this is the result of that analysis and
what you can appreciate immediately is
there's this large block of correlated
features
and within this block we see different
several different markers of
inflammation as well as different
measures of disease severity
also included in here are some
underlying pre-existing health
conditions such as acute kidney disease
and if you go a few rows down what you
can also see is the coordination of that
block
with age and mortality so we can pull
these individual features out
and look at them so this is looking at
several different
serum proteins that are associated with
inflammation
and what you can see is most of these
covid19 patients
are above this green healthy donor
normal range
so what this analysis showed us was that
our copin 19 patients
had a high inflammatory signature that
correlated with many
measures of disease severity as well as
age
and some of the underlying comorbidities
so now we wanted to ask the question
what is the immune response to sars kobe
2 infection
in these hospitalized patients
and in this study we focused on three
different arms of the adaptive immune
system
first are the b cells these are the
cells that are largely responsible for
making antibodies then neutralize the
virus
cd4 t cells these are t cells that
provide all kinds of critical help to
the other cells in the immune system
and cda t cells these cells are
responsible for directly killing and
eliminating virally infected cells
and we profile these cells with a high
dimensional flow cytometry
panel that was then analyzed in the bd
symphony and
in total our panel covered 27 different
parameters
the first thing we looked at was the
relative proportions of these
major immune subsets in their
circulation
what we found was in our copic 19
patients
there was an increase in non-leukocytes
and a
simultaneous decrease in both b cells
and t
cells and when we looked within the t
cell compartment
we found that this decrease tended to be
skewed towards the cd8 lineage
so we were losing more cd8 t cells than
cd4 t
cells this loss of lymphocytes is also
reflected in the clinical data
this is looking at the all lymphocyte
count and what you can see is
approximately half of our patients are
clinically lymphopenic
so we wanted to understand of these
remaining lymphocytes
what is their phenotype
we can analyze this flow cytometry data
in a couple different ways
the first way is basically using manual
gating based on our priori knowledge
and here we can identify known
population subsets
as well as perform functional
phenotyping
so we'll start with the cd8 t cells here
we use
three different surface proteins cd45ra
cd27 and ccr7 to identify various
subsets of naive
effector and memory cells and this is
enumerated on the bottom
and what we found was there is a
decrease in the naive and effector
memory 1 compartment in our covid19
patients
and an increase in the em2 and emra
subsets and what this showed us was that
there is a general sort of global shift
from less differentiated cells to more
terminally differentiated subsets
next we looked at the activated t cell
response
we did this in a couple different ways
on the top i'm showing you
co-expression of hladr and cd38
and on the bottom proliferation as
determined by
the expression of ki-67
what we found was that some of our
covid19 patients
had a very robust high cd8 t-cell
activation and proliferation response
however
there were other patients that had
essentially no response
that were similar to the healthy donors
and this is enumerated on the right hand
side
and so this result was quite remarkable
for two different reasons
one there is a huge amount of
patient-to-patient heterogeneity
so we had some patients with a very
large response and some patients with no
response at all
and also on the higher end of this
activation spectrum
it was really much greater than what we
typically see for other
human viral infections
so the second method we used was
unbiased clustering
and this was a combination of using
tisney and clustering
performed through the cytobank web tool
and it was really important to us to be
able to have an unbiased way of
analyzing the data
because combat 19 is not very well
characterized we didn't want to
necessarily miss anything
because we were only looking for the
cells
that we already knew about
so the first thing we did was to take
all the non-naive cd8 t
cells that were from the healthy donors
the recovery donors or the covet 19
patients
and then we put them on this tisny map
so what you can appreciate immediately
is that there are some portions of this
map
where there are cells that are only
present from the cobit 19 patients
and alternatively you can also see areas
of this map
where you see high density in the
healthy donors in the recovered donors
that are essentially lost or absent in
the covid19 patients
to parse some of these differences we
can then use flowsome clustering on the
tisny axes
to understand what each of these
clusters might be doing biologically and
also sort of their cellular identity
we can look at the individual protein
expression these various markers in our
flow cytometry panel
but what we really wanted to know is how
these various clusters
were differentially distributed between
our three donor cohorts
so on the top i'm showing you three
different clusters clusters one
two and five that were increased in the
covid19 patients
and all of these clusters contained
emory-like cells
that had differential expression of the
transcription factor t-bet
probably the most notable cluster here
on the heat map is cluster 14
and this cluster contained the highly
activated and proliferating cells
so this was nice because it basically
confirmed what we saw with our manual
gating
these are the cells that expressed hladr
in cd38
but we also saw from this unbiased
analysis that they express the
inhibitory receptor pd-1
and fass or cd95 so using this unbiased
method we are able to sort of go beyond
what we had already found with our
manual gating strategy
and i'll point out one more cluster here
cluster 11.
and cluster 11 was interesting because
it's the portion of the map
it's sort of on the lower right hand
side it's very prominent in the healthy
donors
last in the recovered donors and then
basically totally absent from the
covid19 patients
and so this cluster had high expression
of both cx3cr1
and tbet so we think these represent
basically activated effectors
so now we can apply the same kind of
method oh
i'm going to skip forward a few slides
so now we can apply this same method to
to the cd4 t cell response
so first we're going to look at the
activation markers again
hladr and cd38
and so again what you see is a very
robust response
in some of the covid19 patients but
again there's almost no response
in another subset of the copin 19
patients that
are really almost equivalent to the
healthy donors
and you can see that enumerated on the
right hand side here
and i'm going to point out this green
line is representing the 90th percentile
of the healthy donors and so all those
coveted patients that basically fall on
or below that line
are not making any response at all
we can then use the same unbiased
clustering approach using the cytobank
web tool and again we're going to take
our non-naive cd4 t
cells and create a disney map and then
perform flowsome clustering
and again we can then look at the
individual protein expression of these
various clusters
and i'm going to point out two clusters
here cluster
14 and 15 on the bottom and here
these clusters are increased in
proportion in our covid19 patients
cluster 14 is very similar to that
activated proliferating subset
they have high expression of hla dr cd38
and ki-67 and just as we saw with our
cda t-cells they're also expressing
the inhibitory receptor pd-1
and then what was interesting uh is that
we find that this cluster 15
that also we believe represent these
activated effectors they have high
expression of cx3 cr1 and tbit
instead of being decreased in our
coven-19 patients like we saw in the cda
t
cells here in the cd4 lineage they're
actually
increased so taken together we can
basically summarize that we have a
robust cd4 and cd8 t-cell response in
our covid19
cohort but we did see quite a bit of
patient-to-patient heterogeneity in
terms of the magnitude of the response
so what about the b-cells
so when we looked in the peripheral
blood of our coven-19 patients
we saw this massive plasma blast
response
now these are cells these are b cells
that were basically activated in
secondary lymphoid organs such as the
lymph nodes and the spleens
and then in a normal immune response you
will see sort of a transient increase in
the blood
and some of them will transit to the
bone marrow and eventually form
the long-lived plasma cells
so if we compare this to another acute
viral infection such as influenza
we typically only see about 5 to 15
in the blood at the very peak of
infection but here
we're looking at upwards of 40 of all
the circulating b-cells so quite massive
and you know we don't really see this in
any other
acute viral infections the only one that
we could sort of find
that came close was ebola
so this massive plasma response in our
hospitalized patients made us wonder
about
what the circulating antibodies levels
were
so we found that about 70 percent of our
hospitalized patients
made antisars kobe 2 antibody directed
towards the spike
protein so next we compare the level of
this antibody
to that plasmablast response
igm is shown here on the left hand side
and igg is shown at the right hand side
and what was really surprising is that
there was absolutely no correlation
between the plasma blocks response
and the levels of circulating antibody
you know there are probably many
different reasons for this
the first most obvious one is we were
only looking for
antibodies directed towards the spike
protein so these plasma blasts may be
specific
for another viral protein
these plasma blasts also may be lower
affinity so they may be specific for
spike
but just below our level of detection
for our serologic assays
and the third possibility is they're not
specific for stars kobe 2 at all
some proportion of these plasma blasts
may either be
non-specific in just responding to
environmental inflammation
or they may be responding to some kind
of self protein
and it's going to take a lot more work i
think to sort of
figure out what these plasma blasts are
all responding to
so what about the t cells that then help
these b cells in making antibody
so typically during an acute infection
you can see a transient increase in the
blood of these helper t
cells and these helper t cells are
really doing their work
in the secondary lymphoid organs with
the b cells but we can find them in the
blood using these two
different surface proteins pd1 and cxcr5
and now if you drill down on that
circulating tfh subset using two
additional markers
cd38 and icos we know from previous work
that the activated antigen-specific
cells are
in this subset so if we look at the
proportion of these cells
in our covid19 patients and our other
cohorts
if you look at the total circulating tfh
there is no difference at all
between the three cohorts but if you
look at the activated ctfh
we did have an increase in our covid19
patients
and what was interesting is that we also
had an increase
in our recovered donors compared to the
healthy donors
and we think this is because these
donors
had just recently been infected within
two weeks and
germinal centers and these circulating
tfh
can be activated for weeks after an
initial infection
so next we wanted to compare directly
the plasma blast response we saw in the
blood
with this activated ctfh and so what you
can see here
is there's a statistically significant
but weak
correlation between the plasma blast
response and the activated ctfh in the
blood
of our covid19 patients
so then we wanted to compare these
activated ctfh
directly to the antibody levels and
that's shown here
and again what we see is a statistically
significant but relatively weak
correlation
and what this data in some tells us is
that there that there is probably some
amount of t-cell b-cell interactions
going on in the secondary lymphoid
organs
that is leading to the production of
this antibody
so now that we have a handle on the
immune response of coping 19 and these
three different major arms of the immune
system
the b cells the cd4 t cells and the cd8
cells
we wanted to try to understand how these
immune responses
related to those clinical features that
we discussed
at the beginning i'll be showing you one
example here and this is focused on the
cd4 t
cells so here we're taking the
proportion of all of these
manually gated subsets the naive t
cells the central memory the various
effector memory compartments
and then the circulating tfh and these
two
uh subsets of activated t cells the
dr-38 positive
and then the proliferating ki-67
positive cells
and then we compared them to all of
these different clinical features
and i'm only showing you a subset here
the color of the square is indicating
the spearmint corlin
excuse me the spearmint correlation row
statistic
the asterisks are nominal p values and
then because we were doing so many
different comparisons we also calculated
an
adjusted fdr to correct for this
multiple hypothesis correction
testing and so what you can see here
i'll point out a few different things
first cd4 naive t cells
negatively correlate with procalcitonin
and prokasyltonin is one of these
inflammation markers that we can find in
the blood
the second are cd4 t cells that are
either proliferating or activated
they are both positively correlated with
ferritin again
one of these inflammatory markers in the
blood
the activated subset but not the
proliferating subset
was correlated with apache 3
which is basically a measure of
multi-system
organ dysfunction and then the
proliferating subset
also negatively correlated with the
total lymphocyte count
and there are other potentially
interesting relationships that didn't
quite reach
our adjusted fdr cut off so sort of all
together
we found that correlations with we found
correlations with cd4 t cell activation
and then different elements of
inflammation as indicated by the
clinical data
so our next question was how do these
immune responses change over time
in our hospitalized coping 19 patients
and so for patients that were still
admitted to the hospital
seven days later we received a second
blood sample
and then we could compare the two
different time points
so the first part of this analysis was
again to use cytobank
to first create two different disney
maps
the first map included cells that were
present in the day
zero samples and then the second map was
cells present in the day seven samples
and sort of the take home message here
is that you don't see
any sort of you know dramatically global
redistribution
of the cellular density on these plots
between these two different time points
so
relatively few changes over time at this
global level
but what about individual patients
so the example i'm showing here is of
those circulating plasmablasts
and if you look at the two time points
from days year to day seven there's no
statistical difference
but if if you kind of squint you can see
some lines that are going up
some that are going down and then some
that appear to be staying the same
we can actually break this out into
three different groups
so in the top we see five different
donors that have both
time points that are actually increasing
their plasma blast response from day
zero to day seven
the middle group here are patients that
remained relatively stable over that
seven
week excuse me seven day time period
and on the bottom are donors that
decrease their plasma
blast response from the first draw to
the second blood draw
we saw similar sorts of patterns in the
t cell responses
on the left hand side is the activated
cd4 t
cells these dr 38 positives and on the
right hand side are the activated city a
t
cells and again on the top row we can
see
some patients whose response is going up
in the middle
patients whose response is staying
stable and on the bottom
patients whose t-cell responses are
decreasing over time
and what was sort of remarkable about
this result um
both in the t cell compartment but also
thinking about the plasma blast
is that most of these patients that were
stable or increasing in their response
already had elevated levels compared to
the healthy donors
so that meant that these copin 19
patients not only had
elevated bnt cell responses but they
were actually being maintained
over seven days and that is relatively
unusual for an acute viral infection
where we typically see
more transient responses visible in the
blood
so one thing that i've mentioned several
times during this presentation so far
is this huge amount of heterogeneity we
see from patient to patient
and again looking at our green line
that's indicative of the 90th percentile
for these healthy donors
we have some donors that excuse me some
patients that appear not to be making
any response at all so these
observations led us to the hypothesis
that there might be these sort of
global immune phenotypes within our
coping 19 patients
and a related question was how does this
immunologic diversity
relate to various clinical
manifestations and specifically disease
severity
so dr nula and her team had scored these
individual patients based on the nih
ordinal scale score eight was the least
severe
and these individuals had no limitations
in their activities at all
but covent score one meant that the
patients had very severe disease and had
succumbed
to the disease so in order to answer
some of these global questions
we needed a way to take all of those
hundreds of various manually gated
immune populations
and integrate and analyze them at the
same time
and so the method we chose to accomplish
that
is called uniform manifold approximation
and projection
most of you probably know this as you
map so here we are able to take our
approximately 200 immune
features from those individual manual
gating strategies
and put them into the one singular
two-dimensional space
and so you can see on the upper right
hand corner are healthy donors and our
recovery donors
which are segregated quite distinctly
away from almost all the covet patients
and if you notice the coped patients now
are colored by disease score
and you can start to see that perhaps
maybe the
less severe disease patients are closer
to the healthy donors
and then that the donors on the far end
are darker colored and may have more
severe disease
but the data in this format it's sort of
hard to ask that question directly
so we took that diagonal data and we
rotated it and centered it to these two
axes
component one and component two so now
we can directly ask the question
does disease severity relate to
component one
and that's what's shown here so we can
now take
each individual patient's component one
score and plot it
all together in this bar plot so you can
see that the healthy donors
have on average the lowest component one
score
then you have the recovered donors
and then the coveted patients and
stepwise progression
of disease severity and so
we basically had taken these 200 immune
features
created this two-dimensional
distillation and created a global immune
landscape that we can now use to
understand various parts
of the the clinical features including
disease severity
so now let's compare component 1 and
component 2 to the other features in our
clinical data
so again we're using the strategy of
spearmint correlation paired with the
appropriate statistical test
so what you can see on the top is that
component one
is significantly associated with the nih
severity score both at day zero and day
seven
you can see that it is also
significantly correlated with apache 3
which is this measure of multi-organ
system dysfunction
and there's some other interesting sort
of nominal correlations here
some measures of inflammation such as
ferritin and il-6
as well as some of the clinical counts
including pmn which are the neutrophils
and the whole
uh blood cell count
so now we can take this you know total
global immunologic map
and project back onto it individual
uh immune features
so on the left hand side are the
hladrcd38cd4 t cell so these are the
activated cd4 t cells and then we can
ask
are these frequencies statistically
correlated with component one or
component two
and in this case these features are
actually correlated with both
which is why you sort of see this
diagonal pattern between the red and the
blue
in the middle we are looking at the tbep
positive non-nafcd8t
cells and this population is positively
correlated with component 2
but not component one which is why you
see this sort of
horizontal pattern and the last example
is
on the left excuse me the right hand
side the plasma blast
and here the percent of the plasma
blocks in the blood are positively
correlated with component one
but not component two
so you can sort of go through all these
individual features and
and start to understand um the global
distribution
in this immunologic space we also wanted
to understand
how our unbiased flowsome clusters that
were determined by cytobank
could then help us understand these two
different components
so i'll point out a couple different
examples here
here cluster 14 in both the cd8 t cells
and the cd4 t cells were positively
correlated with component one
naive class excuse me non-naivete
cluster cluster 11
that express both t-bet and cx3 cr1 so
these are the activated effectors
here cluster 11 is negatively correlated
with component one but positively
correlative component two
and just one more oh no that's it
um so now
basically we we've taken these 200
immune features
distilled it into a two axis
sort of two-dimensional space and we can
see that
while our patients really exist on the
this full spectrum
um in this immunologic space these two
components have
allowed us to sort of crystallize what
we think are two different
uh types of immune response in the
covid19 patients
so component one relates to this
immunotype one and this is where we have
highly activated cd4 institute t cells
we have lower circulating tfh but
high plasmoblasts and this is correlated
with disease severity
component two you see correlated with
these activated effectors both cd4s and
cd8
proliferating memory b cells and this
sort of immunotype is
not associated with disease severity
so i just described basically two
flavors
of um of immune response but we do know
that there are patients for which we
don't really see any response at all
so we wanted to understand where they're
lying on this map
and so just as a reminder this this
green line is the 90th percentile of the
healthy donors
and so we have these patients that are
lying on or below this line
in many of these features that we looked
at to try to measure the immune response
so we manually defined these as
immunotype 3
and then asked where these fell on this
total immunologic map
and so they're colored here in black and
you can see that our immunotype
3 patients are essentially lower for
both component 1
and component 2 within the covid19
area of the map so then we asked
if you have this immunotype 3 you know
categorical designation
how does that relate to these various
measures of disease severity
and that's listed here on the right hand
side so our immune type 3 patients
basically were negatively
correlated with all measures of that
nih ordinal scale as well as as i just
mentioned the component one
component two so that basically meant
that that these patients that really
weren't uh mounting any kind of immune
response but were still being
hospitalized
actually had less severe disease than
some of the other adults in this cohort
and i'm going to point out one other
thing here which is the way that
the shapes are represented on this map
so the
individuals that are represented by
triangles means that those
individual patients actually passed away
and so we do
have a couple black triangles which
means that we did have some of these
immune type 3 patients
that did succumb to their disease
but what's important about that is we
don't actually know
why the patients are dying and so some
patients may be exhibiting
extreme pathology due to the immune
system but
there are likely other causes that this
disease can be fatal
and that's what's sort of represented
here by the fact that we have these
immune type 3 patients that can still
pass away
so i'll give a brief summary for this
part of the talk
so one of the most notable things that
we discovered in our data was the great
amount of immune heterogeneity
in cobit 19. specifically we saw
this massive plasma blast response that
we really only saw
in other acute infections such as ebola
and dengue
we saw surprisingly that this high
t-cell and b-cell response
was relatively stable over time in some
patients
and using high dimensional analysis we
are able to define basically three
different flavors of the immune system
that link to different forms of clinical
manifestation
and i think this work has a really
important implications and leads
to many many outstanding questions
first i think the most important thing
to realize is that we need to consider
the
patient's immune response and thinking
about how to treat each individual
patient
there are now hundreds of trials
probably thousands worldwide
trying different kinds of strategies to
treat covid19 patients
and you have the whole spectrum from
immunosuppressants
to immune activating drugs and
what i've shown you here is that some
patients don't make any response at
all so those are definitely not patients
that you would want to put on
immunosuppressants
so we need to be able to come up with a
way to
quickly assess the immune status of
these patients and treat them
appropriately
a second major question is a lot of
these hospitalized covenanting patients
they are making neutralizing antibody
and yet they're really sick
and so we need to understand why that
neutralizing antibody
is not able to control the virus in
these patients
the third question is what i just
brought up which is why are these
patients
really so sick is it immune pathology is
it um
viral mediated um we still don't
understand
and it's probably very different for
each individual patient
and sort of the last interesting thing
that i think about a lot is if are these
differences
related to kinetics there's some
emerging evidence that suggests
that early viral control is very
important
and part of this is perhaps an
interferon response
so it's possible that the patients
that end up getting very sick and end up
requiring hospitalization
are patients that when infected with
cyrus kobe 2
fail to control the virus
spread early and and then it basically
turns into a runaway train
but understanding the kinetics of this
response in different donors is going to
be really important
so in the last few minutes i'm going to
tell you a little bit about our new work
which is trying to understand the immune
responses to covid and kids
so at the same time that we are
collecting samples for our adult cohort
we are also collecting samples from two
different pediatric cohorts
at the children's hospital of
philadelphia
we had one cohort which is the cobit 19
cohort
and this cohort was divided up into two
groups
one that experienced ards acute
respiratory distress syndrome
and the second that did not so this
helped
basically as a measure of severity for
copenhagen disease in this pediatric
group
the second group were a group of
pediatric patients that were diagnosed
with ms c
so miss c is stands for multi-system
inflammatory syndrome in children
the cdc definition here are individuals
that are
less than 21 years of age they have to
present with fever
inflammation and multi-system organ
involvement and also have a saris cov2
positive test but the experience
at chop has been that these are kids
that are
you know even robustly healthy
absolutely no
previous sickness and then they get
really really sick
and some of the most common features
here are
fever rash gi involvement
and a significant portion of these kids
complain
of a very acute abdominal pain
and occasionally some of these patients
and we do know have had family members
they have document documented infection
three to four weeks prior to this misty
diagnosis
so this is sort of what the caseload
looked like in philadelphia
the adult covid cases peaked around late
mid to late april and then basically
three to four weeks later we had this
increase in misc diagnosis um
cases at the children's hospital
and so just this timing alone sort of
raises some interesting questions
um first of all were these missy
patients basically infected with
steroids kobe 2 around the same time as
the adults
but then have had some kind of long
chronic infection
and if that's true what what
then is the cause for them to develop
these acute symptoms
is there a secondary event such as
another viral infection
um reactivation of a of you know sort of
an adonis chronic viral infection like
cmv
or some other kind of secondary event
maybe autoimmune
so just a note about the analysis for
this cohort
our primary statistical comparisons here
are misc
versus the pediatric covin-19 but what
was really great was because all of
these samples were
collected stained and processed at the
same time as the adult
we could then actually use the adult
sample
as basically a comparator and this
helped us have a framework for
understanding
these immune responses both in the
pediatric coveted as well as the missy
so just like the adults we had various
features of clinical metadata
so what i'm showing you on the left hand
side are
two different measures of serum
inflammation so ferritin
and d-dimer and you can see that the
misc kids here in the green triangles
have all have elevated levels of both of
these serum proteins indicating global
inflammation
and on the right hand side you're
looking at the all lymphocyte count
and most of the missing kids are below
the the healthy donaire range and are
clinically lymphopenic
we can now use our high dimensional flow
cytometry to study the immune response
and first we're looking at these major
immune subsets
and what we see in the missy kids is a
little bit different from what we saw
in both the adult copen19 and the
pediatric
covid19 which is an increase in the
proportion of b
cells but then similar to the adults
the misc are decreased in the proportion
of t
cells with the cd4 t cells but more
dramatically the cda t
cells and we can see that the misty
kids here basically look like the
sickest adults in terms of the percent
of cdht cells
so now we're going to look at the t cell
activation again using some of those
same markers we described earlier what
we can see
is that um there there is a small
percent of
activated cd4 and cd8 t cells in the
pediatric
19 patients but if you look at the misc
examples here there's a huge expansion
of both the activated cd4
and cda t cells in circulation and this
is enumerated on the right hand side
and so if you look down on the bottom
specifically at the cdat cells
the miss c patients have either on par
or even greater
levels of cd8t cell activation compared
to the sickest adults
so one of the things that we are
interested in was to try to understand
if these cd8 t-cells were not just
activated but perhaps
actually exhibiting signs of t-cell
exhaustion
and this was we thought an intriguing
question especially because of that
timing i talked about earlier between
the
when we saw the covet 19 adult cases
come in much earlier in april and then
this
missy sort of wave coming in three to
four weeks later indicating that
these kids may have been infected for
quite a while and so t-cell exhaustion
is a state that can happen in chronic
viral infection in cancer
when t-cells are chronically stimulated
and then eventually become dysfunctional
so the first way that we assess this was
to look at the inhibitory receptor
pd-1 and so we saw that indeed
our misc patients had an increase in
pd-1 expression
both in the cd4 t cells shown here on
the top and the cd8 cells shown on the
bottom
compared to the pediatric covid19
and we know that pd-1 by itself is not a
good
indication of exhaustion because it can
also be transiently
increased in activated t-cells so we
looked at a secondary
inhibitory receptor cd39
and while it didn't reach statistical
significance our misc patients
the majority of them did have increased
city 39 compared to the pediatric cohort
and really one of the characteristic
signs of t-cell exhaustion
is the high expression of multiple
inhibitory receptors
and we know specifically that
co-expression of pd-1 and cd39
marx exhausted t cells an adult chronic
infection like hiv
as well as cancer so then we examined
the co-expression of both of these
inhibitory receptors in the citigate t
cells and that's what we see here
and indeed there is a statistically
there's a statistical increase in the
number of cd t
cells expressing both of these
inhibitory receptors in the misty
patients
so the last thing we wanted to
understand here uh was again how the
immune system was changing over time
and this was uh particularly interesting
in these missy patients because when
these kids first show up the hospital
they're really sick and in a scary kind
of way
but luckily with the right treatments
these
individual patients almost always
recover
and are able to be discharged and do
just fine and so we wanted to understand
what the immune system looks like at
those different time points when they
came in and they were really sick
and also uh what they looked like when
their clinical symptoms were improving
so we had three different misty patients
where we were able to collect
two different time points and ask how
the immune system was changing
over that time
so since the cd8t cell activation
response was sort of one of the most
remarkable things
about these patients we first looked at
the
the percent of cd 38 and dr positive
cells
at the first draw compared to the second
draw so that's what you see here
and each row represents one donor so at
the first draw you see this very
elevated
acidity t-cell response that is
significantly decreased by the second
draw
and that's enumerated here on the on the
top plot
and then we looked at another sorry
several other
t cell activation markers including k-67
which denotes these proliferating cells
we looked at pd-1
and also looked at the change in these
double positive pd-1
city 39 double positive cells and
basically all of these various measures
of t cell activation decrease between
those two
time points we then asked how the
clinical
features were changing over those time
points
and so if you look at the top left hand
side here that's the olympic site count
so as i noted at the beginning the miss
c kids tend to have
lower lymphocyte counts and some are
lymphopenic but here what we can see by
that second time point that lymphocyte
count has actually recovered to almost
healthy normal domain range
we can also look at these various
measures of inflammation
and sort of the take-home message here
is that while
many of the kids do not necessarily
reach the healthy donor range
you are starting to see a decrease in
this global
this global sort of inflammation that we
see
and i'll just summarize um this last
part of the talk uh and what i've shown
you here
is that the syndrome misty is
characterized by very high t-cell
activation
and this really rivals uh what we see in
the sickest covid19
adult i've also shown you some evidence
that the cd8t cells msc may be exhausted
but it's going to take a lot more work
to determine if that's true
and i've also shown you that while
there's a resolution of clinical
symptoms
this does coincide with the decrease in
t cell activation
and of course that sort of leaves a lot
of questions about what the pathology of
this disease is
and whether this is just sort of
coincidental
or if this disease is actually mediated
in part by this high degree of t cell
activation
and i'll just point out of course so
much more work to be done here
with this with this misty syndrome
and with that um i would like to
acknowledge all of my many collaborators
of course john wary my p.i um
and underlined here uh in the weary lab
i've listed all of the the
co-6 authors on the original science
paper
and in green here are my my co-authors
that have
contributed to the work on the miss c
this whole covet blood processing unit
on the bottom
and i want to point out amy baxter
really built this from the ground up
in the middle of the pandemic it was a
huge effort
and lots of people contributed really
volunteered their time
newla meyer who initiated all this work
in the clinical side
many many other labs at penn including
at the children's hospital of
philadelphia
and i'll just thank my funding sources
especially of course cri
and then mark foundation and i'm happy
to take any questions
thank you josephine for your informative
presentation
we would now like to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
does hydroxychloroquine alter the immune
response in coca-19 adult patients
um yep that's an interesting question so
some of our patients i think about
45 did receive that treatment
there were some nominal associations
with some of the various forms of
t-cell activation but that probably is
more to do with
just how sick those patients were and
not necessarily any direct effect of the
drug itself
okay great thank you the next question
is
what types of pre-existing conditions do
the adult patients have
i'm actually really glad you asked xa i
forgot to mention it
um so most of our most of our adult
cohort had significant comorbidities
um i believe about 80 of them had some
kind of
cardiovascular pre-existing condition
i know about 40 also had diabetes um 45
were obese and so our adult
covid19 uh cohort had a lot of these
underlying comorbidities
and this is really interesting because
it was sort of in stark contrast to what
we saw with
the miss c patients where those kids had
absolutely no underlying conditions and
were really robustly healthy
so that was sort of an interesting
contrast in the two sort of severe forms
of the disease that we're seeing
okay thank you and our next question is
do serum antibody levels correlate with
disease severity
um surprisingly they do not at all
okay and do the miss see patients
have cobia covered antibodies
right um so i didn't show that data
today um
but yes they do so we've measured uh
again um
antibody directed towards the spike
protein uh in the cyroscopy ii
uh virus and all of our
missy kids are seropositive and it's
actually a defining feature of the
disease
oh wow okay we've got one more question
does the cd4 t cell response also change
over time in the misc patients
right um so the misc patients were
characterized by both high
cd8 and cd4 responses um
and yes the the answer is yes we also
see a decrease over time from that
that first blood draw to the second
blood draw in
the the cda and the cd4 responses
all right well thank you again josephine
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckmann coulter life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye